foreign
the German Sports firm Adidas has
traditionally been the reigning Champion
when it comes to football branding but
for the third consecutive World Cup
American sportswear company Nike is
sponsoring more shirts than its rivals
[Music]
or deals with 13 of the 32 national
teams in the tournament including
favorites Brazil Adidas has designed
shirts for only seven one is Mexico's
away shirt inspired by a mythical
Feathered Serpent and Japan's home kit
incorporates elements of popular
Japanese comics
brand experts say companies are under a
lot of commercial pressure to produce a
shirt that sells well
[Music]
looking for a standout design uh
something that's attractive gets a lot
of notice and primarily that the fans
will buy that's the the main objective
is to get as many replica sales as they
can over a relatively short period of
the event not all designs have been well
received the front of Switzerland's
shirt designed by German firm Puma has
been likened to a QR code and added as
his shirt for Algeria has angered
Morocco it says the geometric blue teal
and yellow design is common in Moroccan
mosaics and amounts to cultural
appropriation the situation today is
really bad and if Adidas had really
looked at that I mean it's yeah it's
something that that happens when you
have a multinational in Germany
designing shirts for a culture that they
may not be familiar with
tensions between countries will be high
on the pitch off it the battle of the
brand is its own high-stakes affair